[Music]
i went to a co-ed junior high school and
in eighth grade i was the second
shortest person in my class i was
second only to judy will lotion judy if
you're listening uh thank you for that
but the next year i i desperately wanted
to play football and i was four foot
nine and i weighed 89 pounds i know that
because we did away in before the
tryouts and
my coach said to me you know after he
basically said i was never going to play
he said you should try wrestling because
you're so small no one will be in your
weight group you'll they'll have to
forfeit every match so
so you'll just win all these matches and
probably be undefeated
and
so as as sad as i was about not being
able to play football i went to one
wrestling
practice and um there was something
about
grappling with other men at that age
that i just couldn't not to be
homophobic i thought you were going to
say that you just didn't want to win by
forfeit every time oh no
that would have been great
no i didn't want to i didn't want to
question my sexuality which was uh
already you know tenuous life could be a
dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your not as short as i used to be host
justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
clever thanks thanks uh you're so clever
you're always clever i'm here with my
supportive brother
christian
christian long did you ever uh play with
the idea of doing sports in high school
uh yes i played baseball i did i played
baseball and basketball um but i was
never i was a late bloomer like you you
don't both have to be late bloopers so i
was uh
i
i hadn't gone through puberty until like
sophomore year in high school and by
that point i was kind of puberty by that
point i was a little behind the eight
ball uh in terms of you know
being big enough to play and all that i
certainly never considered wrestling
um nor was i ever interested in
professional wrestling no i wasn't
either and our guest today is
a very famous
pro wrestler i'm still not still not but
but uh
it was really interesting meeting yes
this is our first
uh pro wrestler we've ever had on the
show first of many guys
the fir i would say unless i'm
forgetting the first athlete of any kind
right yeah yeah we've been wanting to
have uh more non-actors and i know a lot
of the feedback for the show has been
that um so this was exciting on that
level too and just like just to change
up the show a little bit but yeah like
you said i because i had so little
knowledge of what this world was it was
interesting to talk to somebody who was
like at the top of that world so our
guest is chris jericho and even though i
know next to nothing about professional
wrestling i know that name yeah that's
how famous he is i know nothing about
what he does really
but i definitely are you know i'm sure
you know that name because yeah is a
famous no i definitely know that name i
mean there's a handful of wrestlers
whose names i know like yeah like john
kogan john cena but the
uh the roddy roddy piper yes
flare well part of it too is a lot of
these guys uh crossed over in some way i
was gonna say that yeah i'm sorry about
the rock no it's okay yeah um the rock i
have never heard a bad word about the
rock
i haven't either by all accounts he's
just like
the most the most solid human being i
met him briefly once we both were in a
an animated movie called planet51 uh and
we we did press together one day and he
he was just the most charming
but to the point where you know it it it
forces you to question like well what's
really going on how can anyone be that
well maybe one day we'll have him on the
show but today we have
right right an equally charming person
yes yes jericho you weren't into
wrestling as a kid we uh justin and i
and our brother damian as kids we used
to play call a game called goomba yeah
do you remember that of course i
remember we would take pillows these big
pillows from our couch um
and stand on either end of our we call
it our family room and say goomba and
we'd run at each other kind of like sumo
wrestling style and we would just knock
each other i've seen people doing
versions of that where they're in those
big puffy uh like translucent balloon
suits but we used to play goomba and i
think that was the closest
connection to pro wrestling that i ever
had do you know why we called it goomba
i'm trying to remember uh no i i just
thought it was so funny yeah it is fun
to say
weren't there goombas in super mario
brothers that word was for some reason
in our vernacular sometimes we used to
like adopt these like silly sounding
words just because they were fun to say
yeah
um so i was never into pro wrestling
because i remember learning when i was a
kid in school that it was fake
right when i learned that i was like
stupid why would i like this if it's
fake you know what's crazy is that
christian and i believed in santa claus
and and easter bunny much later than
i think most kids embarrassing i was
like yeah i was like 10. well here's the
most embarrassing thing because one year
my uncle dressed up as the easter bunny
and it was so convincing and he ran
around our yard and like the ears would
pop up and i'd be like look look over
there and my parents would turn and they
did a really good job of like
convincingly like you know playing dumb
i was so sure i had seen the easter
bunny that even after i realized santa
claus thing
in fifth grade for like a year after i
still continued to believe in the easter
bunny so in fact i remember hearing kids
in school like talk about it oh you were
the easter bunny i remember thinking you
fools it's funny to to be like santa
claus obviously [ __ ] right now uh
tooth fairy come on who would believe
that but easter bunny yeah a rabbit
because i've seen it i thought i had
seen it i think the easter bunny is the
most uh of those three the most retailed
the most ridiculous is that wouldn't you
say uh yeah tooth fairy is pleasant
already makes the most sense garrett
tooth very scary mention some little
like goblin like going into what you're
sleeping but they leave a nice thing at
least yeah here's what also didn't make
sense pro wrestling right but
i think we were both really interested
to learn more about it and maybe
gain a
new perspective yeah from uh one of the
greatest that's kind of one of the
points of the show and it was something
that we hadn't really explored um
as much as we do in this episode
something that we had no frame of
reference for so chris jericho is like i
said a very famous wrestler but he's
also
the lead singer of a band called fozzie
and he hosts a podcast of his own that's
been on for like five or six years yeah
called talk is jericho i was curious to
talk to somebody who had been doing this
is a very new thing for us uh as you as
you can tell and um
and so i was also curious to talk to him
about that this guy wears
so many
hats yeah i hate that experience but we
both just uh jinxed on it yeah one two
three four five what was that thing with
james
what wasn't there a rule with jinx where
uh you'd count
ten ten and if you got there before
punching somebody there's a whole
punching thing god boys are so stupid
you know i've been hosting i've been
hosting this like kids show and uh it's
been so fun but these kids on it they're
like 11 12 13. and i had forgotten this
there's one kid who um he's kind of shy
but all of a sudden he started doing
this like you know when you make the
the circle with your hand and you have
to like stick your finger through it
yeah i remember that yeah he's really
good at it this kid and he's been doing
it to me a lot and he'll punch me
afterwards when he gets me and you can't
punch him back no i once got him sort of
and i was like ah let it go he's gonna
punch him
please don't punch him no no no i won't
this podcast won't be on much longer if
you punch a kid
in the arm
anywhere i know you can't no punching
wow chris jericho really fired you up
yeah he really had an effect on me so um
um hopefully he'll have an effect on you
too uh coming up right after the break
uh my interview with chris jericho
life could be a dream sweetheart
it's no secret that christian and i love
the bachelor we talk about it all the
time
perhaps to the detriment of the show
especially the listeners who are not
familiar with a bachelor but if you're
one of those people and you've been kind
of curious about it maybe you want to
dip your toes into the bachelor world
into the bachelor pool bachelor verse
yeah bachelor national nation if you
want to get citizenship and you know
sign up for citizenship and bachelor
nation maybe the way you want to do that
then is to listen to a podcast about it
stay tuned to the end of this episode
for a preview of bachelor happy hour
with rachel and ali
i know for a fact that you're that you
listen to podcasts because you're doing
it right now unless this was but some
weird mistake and it just came on um and
in that case sorry yeah sorry but yeah
also maybe keep listening you might like
it yeah don't turn us off five stars
five stars please please uh so
stay tuned to the end of the episode for
a preview of bachelor happy hour with
rachel and ali
don't forget to subscribe to bachelor
happy hour on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you're listening to this right
now on purpose or by mistake
hello hello again
we'll meet again
in the words of william shatner uh i can
hear you why do i need headphones
try these ones okay in the words of
leonard nimoy here try these
and don't even repeat what james duhan
said oh yeah oh no no no no that's some
of the best that's that's very good here
this is a perfect example of something
that i i often think about when i start
these is that
i just met you for the first time and
and we're we're getting coffee and and
and i can't help but think i wish this
was all being recorded it's such a
telling
part of one's relationship the is the
first few seconds and you strike me as
such a nice person such a nice connected
you said hi to everyone you were very
present with everybody uh not just a
major star like me right well i mean i
was actually really really uh
intimidated to see you but i saw your
brother first and thought it was you oh
and i kind of broke the ice a bit oh
that's right
but you seem like a genuine as somebody
that i wouldn't peg as being when i
think of a and i don't know much about
wrestling which is another reason i'm
excited to talk to you i uh don't you
don't strike me as somebody who who
would choose
it's show business right right so that's
how you and one thing about working in
wrestling is specifically in the wwe my
my old company
[Music]
um not to be confused
um is that there's no room for prima
donnas there um
if you start getting too big for your
own britches they'll remind you that
this is
all
about the fans and about public
relations and isn't that interesting
because yeah a lot of those wrestlers
that i remember from the 80s were built
their reputations on being or their
personas anyway on being prima donnas
yeah well it's also the 80s things were
different there was much more of a wild
west thing now it's corporate it's
publicly traded we're going for the big
sponsors and you're on the you know the
the jimmy fallon show whatever it may be
so you and plus
if you're not a dick you should be nice
to everybody of course because it's
something that ozzy taught me years ago
you always be nice to everybody because
you never know who's who in the room
right the guy that looks like the
freaking roadie could be the number one
producer in the world or the guy or the
number one
either one that's kind of cool it could
be the worst roadie in the world if you
don't know but but the point is is that
you should be friendly and nice to
everybody and here's another thing too
we have a mutual friend we talked about
kevin smith
kevin's the nicest guy so when he's
talking uh glowingly about justin long
or chris jericho you feel like you know
each other anyway that's true
yeah and we've never been in a kevin
movie together but i've done two you've
done three four five six whatever
you know that this guy's not going to be
a dick no matter what yeah and i know
chris kevin's chris kevin's not one to
to gush about somebody that in a phony
way so i also and i really trust him
like you said he's a very nice person
he's a grounded guy uh so when he speaks
and he was he was singing your praises
he has been um
and he said what a great actor you were
in the thing you did uh which i think is
something that surprised him and that
it doesn't surprise me only because like
you said what you do in in the wrestling
world a lot of it is performing all of
it it's all yeah wrestling is acting
that's the most important thing is
connecting with an audience what
percentage would you say because there
obviously is a very physical element
there's an athletic element sure i mean
for me
uh doing this for 30 years and kind of
seeing them come and see him go i'd say
75 is personality wow i mean if you can
have a great match and you have
personality well then you'll be a mega
star if you are the worst wrestler but
you have the best personality and you
can connect with the audience like i'm
sure you remember the ultimate warrior
for example uh not a great performer in
the ring oh really but connected with
the crowd and captivated the crowd and
that's the same thing in rock and roll
or comedy or acting if you can connect
with the audience ric flair would you
say he was uh he was a combination of
the two he could have a great match but
was also just over the top personality
yeah total package were you always like
that when you were a kid where you're
very outgoing yes
yeah like i wanted to be a wrestler
since i was about 12 or 13. i wanted to
be in a rock and roll band since i was
about 12 or 13 because it's the show
business element of it you know like my
dad used to play he was on the rangers
he was in the rangers yeah yeah so you
grew up in you grew up they were
canadian but you grew up in new york
yeah yeah exactly so um
my point is though i liked hockey but it
was a team sport with a group of guys
all dressed the same and you didn't
really know which guy was which if you
didn't see their numbers on the back
especially when they started wearing
helmets
wrestling music you knew who paul
stanley was you knew who hulk hogan was
you know you stood out yeah they stood
out they were a character on top of
being an athlete and a musician or
whatever maybe so those were the guys
that you watch and who specifically did
you watch as a kid and think both both
as a musician and a wrestler who did you
emulate um i mean my first probably huge
fanaticism was for hulk hogan sure um
you know right in the right era right
age for hulkamania and then ricky
steamboat ricky the dragon steamboat
because he was much more of a of a
wrestler a high flyer they called him
and i was really attracted to that
element of it
what was it about wrestlers because i
remember the kids there were a lot of
kids in my school in my class who were
you from by the way from fairfield
connecticut got you okay right so i went
to the you know as the riverfield
elementary and then i remember clearly
kids were really into it connecticut is
the home of wwe that's where the
officers are in stamford i mean that's a
big wrestling area it was huge when i
was growing and i just didn't understand
i didn't unders so what was i i do now
but much better and i understand the
performance element but i think at the
time there were still some kids that
thought maybe it was real
it was that age you did i thought it was
because in the 80s you didn't know
there's no internet there was no like
insider sheets and you know people told
you uh some people would tell you that
all that stuff's not real or the the
dirty word oh that's fake and you would
defend it i bet yeah yeah you know and
and i still defend the word fake i think
it's a terrible description for
wrestling because yeah it's it's
predetermined that's true it's a story
it's real it is real stuff that you're
doing is real it's a real life it's a
combination shakespearean morality play
and live stunt show that you go see at
knott's berry farm here's the indiana
jones show you know something could go
wrong you can get seriously hurt
obviously if you and i are wrestling
we're working together we don't want to
really hurt each other but it's it's a
it's a stunt sure in a movie and the
truth is drama is such an important
element of sports in general i mean of
all of all sports and
it's for me it's one of the more
important elements like i for example
with baseball i don't i enjoy the game
but not enough to actually go and get
into it
to follow the stats and like who's on
top of the east and but when october
rolls around you can be sure i'm like
sure i'm getting excited playoff games
the stakes are higher so i i or if
there's a fight in hi i mean obviously
hockey
was that difficult watching your dad
or or no you must have enjoyed stuff
like fighting in hockey or well i mean i
mean i i by the time my dad was finished
i was seven so i mean but my dad was a
fighter like i go back now and watch oh
really yeah that was his thing regulate
what do they call it uh enforcer
enforcer but he was also a goal scorer
too he was a kind of a power forward is
what you call them in modern day back in
the 70s you just called them like third
line grinders but he could score 20
goals a year as well which is no mean
feat wow yeah so you know it'll go back
and watch the stuff is pretty cool um
you know the advent of youtube allows me
to kind of really see my dad's career
from a different side because as a kid i
remember sitting in the in the garden
and watching him skate around but being
mad that he wouldn't look up and wave to
me ah right
like a three-year-old kid you know yeah
um
or the crowd being so loud that i pulled
my little
sweater that my grandma had knit for me
over my ears to cover the noise because
it was too loud
i remember those things you know now you
see the kids with the you know rock kids
i have friends who are musicians and
they bring the kids they have their
babies
put the cans on oh well so so your
memories of that were it was like just
from throughout the child
child
it wasn't a child's eyes yeah and were
you ever do you ever remember getting
scared when your dad would get into a
fight no cause i don't remember him ever
getting into a fight okay you know i'm
sure he did yeah but is he are you close
with your dad yeah yeah yeah but like i
said watching him now
is it's it's quite it's quite cool and i
think even for him because back in those
days he didn't really see anything
nobody's recording the game to watch
later on if you're playing the game it's
true you're not watching it even if you
are on you know hockey night in canada
or whatever i almost said people forget
that but i forget that i forget yeah you
forget how the world yeah that's right
how things there was such a mystery to
most things well yeah and even like when
i first started wrestling i remember
like if there was a wrestling magazine
you had a picture of you in it you would
cut it out and save it but that was
almost frowned upon like
what do you call it being a mark like
would have been a mark for yourself you
know you'd like uh it could be fanboying
yourself oh it's lame it's lame to kind
of like save these things i guess it's
true that uh of actors as well to like
clip out your own [ __ ]
but then but then in retrospect but i
was excited about it well sure like when
you're first starting out like it's it's
one of those things that somebody said
to me and and and other i remember like
someone asked gene simmons what's your
favorite part of your career and he's
like the beginning like the very
beginning when when the world was yeah
ahead of you you didn't know like it's
true thinking back to those days totally
you know i was just thinking about this
the other day i used to live in a
one-bedroom apartment in vancouver with
two other guys when i was wrestling
mostly in japan so vancouver's a quick
flight and i remember we pulled our
money together to buy shake and baked
chicken and cherry pie we were cooking
in the kitchen i remember i vividly
remember i love shaking
vividly remember my uh
roommate going like like we're eating
like kings man like remember these days
these some days we'll look back on these
days as the best days of our lives
and probably two pretty not maybe not
the best days it's a pretty damn good
time yeah
oh yeah 25 years ago now totally i do
think holy [ __ ] man i know the only
thing i wish i could combine is knowing
being a little bit more now comfortable
with myself and being
i just knowing myself better i wish i
could combine that and the history that
i've had and all the years that with the
newness of everything and the excitement
of yeah you know yeah but like you never
like and you're like you're not like
this either because i can tell
jaded like people get jaded i'm never
jaded like every time i get to do
something like even this podcast today
it's like far out i just lost podcast
that's great but when people start
getting jaded because they've done it
all totally that's when you start
regressing and we've both seen examples
with that yeah i'm thinking of some very
clear ones right now which are upsetting
to see like
an actor for example that i really
admire that i've admired for years and
and you get to either work with them or
or just meet them and and they reek of
that you know of like um no lo this is
there's no longer any joy in this for me
it's it's become very sterile yeah it's
just a job there's no choice it's just a
job yeah when you start thinking if
something is just a job
you know stop i had moments where i
i could see myself going that way and
there were certain jobs i look back on
and think yeah i took this for granted
and i wasn't appreciating this in the as
much as i i i
i wish i had been you know i i do not
it's weird i kind of appreciate these
things more and the older you get the
more you appreciate what is what's going
on i
i don't know like time is becoming i
think i think when when you're younger
you
maybe don't understand as much
just like for example if you're acting
and like from what i'm recalling from
you from you the first time i saw you
was probably maybe jeepers creepers yeah
you might have done stuff before that
but that's the one i remember and like
maybe at the time you just thought
or anybody like i'm the lead in this
movie like there's going to be a hundred
likes 100 different movies yeah you know
what i mean like and maybe just don't
take it it's funny i'm looking back at
that and like it was so the opposite of
that i was so excited to be okay in fact
we were in the middle of uh you guys
shot uh with you shot a movie with kevin
in sarasota area we should get to that
but but so we were in northern florida
okay yeah and and
is there swamps or really like horse
country like central like ocala county
and the crew there were a lot of la guys
there on that jeepers creepers crew and
um they were always complaining about
being there and i
loved it i
we shot a lot of nights so you know
you're on a reverse schedule and uh on
our days off there was literally nothing
to do except go to walmart i got to know
everyone who worked there the whole
skeleton crew you know the whole like a
great grave ship you know what's funny
is uh i was resting in tennessee in 94.
it's my first time out of canada
and you might as well have gone to the
planet mars like canada tennessee you
know very strange place yeah um but the
same thing i lived in a dry county
called morristown tennessee outside of
knoxville yeah and what we used to do at
night is just go hang out at the walmart
isn't it see that maybe we can find some
chicks at the walmart at 1 30 in the
morning
the walmart bringing the world together
but my point being what we're saying is
that like i think as you get older you
you take more uh
um i don't know maybe more pride or more
more uh thankful for what you've
accomplished yeah it may be as simple as
like time you recognize that time is
yeah you know it's dwindling yeah and to
get and to get to the point where if
you're a leading man or if you're a
world champion or if you have a hit song
or whatever it may be it's like there's
millions of people right that work their
lives totally specific craft and never
achieve it and not to be morbid but
you've probably have we both i'm sure
i've seen more people
leave this life and yeah god they can
happen
it's like not that far off and it can
happen at any point and so time becomes
that much better that's right you're
right and you're actually more
appreciative of what you've done are you
you grew up wearing did you grow up in
winnipeg oh winnipeg okay so so were you
a were you a hockey fan were you a jets
fan yeah huge man like if you grew up in
winnipeg it was all
wrestling heavy metal and hockey
and then and then beer when you get to
be 16. so so what did you excel most out
of those four things rank them in
at the time
now like looking back like what have you
excelled at obviously hockey is probably
hockey's the worst yeah beer drinking
that was really good
but i mean wrestling in music like i
said that's what i wanted to do yeah my
whole life right pretty incredible yeah
well it's interesting because my kids
now my son is is going to be 16
and my daughter's gonna be 13 over the
next couple months
and um like i already knew what i wanted
to do at that age it's a very rare thing
now whether you want to be
a wrestler or a sword swallower or a
mime in the circus right there mimes in
the circus whatever uh there should be
am i i'm on the streets of perry a mime
anywhere that's the great thing about
mimes they could just appear and you
wouldn't know it because you can't hear
them they're just like is there mine
behind me right now very good i wish
is the justin long here's the justin
long show mime dancers ladies and
gentlemen you should ignore him he just
hangs out there i just haven't i just
like to keep the guests on their toes my
point being is is if you know what you
want to do at a young age and you go for
it really really
gives you much more purpose but here's
the thing you wanted to do you happen to
want to do two things that that
like so many kids and teenagers want to
do kids that age
that's the fantasy job either one of
those
a pro wrestler or a rock star the fact
that you manifested the fact that both
of those became a reality is i think
that's the rare thing it's not like kids
13 14 year olds are like i really want
to be an accountant yeah to be a
chartered accountant would be a dream
you know but like you had this like a
fantasy that you were lucky enough to
and not just lucky but driven i'm sure i
was told by so many people oh you'll
never do that why why would they tell
you that i just i i must have been a big
guy at that age you must have been no no
i mean i was not that big i mean when i
first started when i went to wrestling
school at 19 i mean i'm 5 11 maybe and i
was probably 190. this is in the land of
the giants back in those days when most
of the stars andre the giants yeah hulk
hogan snake ultimate warriors
[Music]
and has like this gentle has like a
another really cool such a nice humble
uh
quiet yes guy
yes so not that wrestling person right
right and then once again i think that
that's the thing like you mentioned
before i didn't think you'd be so
friendly or whatever whatever the point
was it's like we're playing characters
as well
um i just played this character for you
know 20 years it's a very long time to
play the character but still you have to
slip into it how would you describe that
character if you were to if you were to
write it in a script well i mean i
always when i first like i have had a
bunch of different characters because i
try and evolve constantly i'm a big
inspiration
from david bowie who always changed his
look in his character and had different
personalities that he played which kept
his fans on their toes and gave him a
very long career and a diverse career
but i think probably i mean if you're
looking at the original y2j character
that i played when i first went to the
wwe yeah you're 19 you're in like
wrestling well this is 19
you're playing different characters when
i when i really got to wwe in 1999. how
did that happen i'm sorry i'm sorry to
interrupt and go back but how hard was
it to breaking because you wanted a so
you're a kid you're a teenager you have
this dream i want to be a wrestler to go
from that to the wwe which is like
you know you mentioned i i was now
thinking about all the kids who love
wrestling and fantasize about doing that
but how do you realize that dream i mean
how do you go for it and like i said
growing up especially in winnipeg in the
80s wrestling was huge huge huge huge in
that city and huge around the world so
it was a real
fertile time there's a lot of kids that
want to be wrestled but your kids
want to be astronauts too or want to be
indiana jones or whatever
i never lost this goal to be a wrestler
um
and also too growing up where i where i
did all we heard about was wwf there was
no you know nwa you mentioned rick flair
earlier he wasn't really on the radar
because he worked for another company
that we never really saw
so michael
one was called wcw which was owned by
ted turner right in atlanta and then
vince mcmahon owned the wwe
right in new york
but to me all those other companies were
great but i didn't give a [ __ ] you
weren't exposed to them i wasn't exposed
to them but i did i wanted to work for
the wwe okay
problem was i was too small at the time
for what wrestling was right so i found
places to go where it didn't matter your
size mexico
i became a huge star in mexico and japan
those countries were more
focused on the the wrestling quality as
far as in the ring does that mean the
actual
is it matches quote unquote real i hate
using that well it's it's it's strong
style that's what they call it which is
it is more real it's it's much more
hard-hitting but it's much more about
the athleticism and the technique okay
it's more choreographed well yeah just
but more about the like about yeah being
able to do flips and jumps yeah more
entertaining matches with more high
spots we call them and it was less about
the personality although you still
needed it and more about what you could
do in the ring which is the way
wrestling is nowadays too it's moved
forward into that but at the time
a guy like me could become a big star in
japan or become a big star in mexico uh
germany
those places and then start working
smaller companies in the states i
mentioned tennessee and there was a big
one called ecw based out of new york and
then that's how people started hearing
about you so that when wwe finally
found out who i was in about 99 wasn't
about the big size as much as the
personalities and so it's good timing i
mean it's just your own drive and all
that but it's also it coincided with a
time where the entire industry yeah the
entire evolved it's like playing hockey
30 years ago like they'll never there's
never going to be another gretzky uh
that can get 215 points in a season not
because you're not going to have a guy
that talented you might yeah but the
game has changed so so this takes how
many i'm trying to get these it takes
like seven eight nine years nine years
before i made my debut in the wwe and
what was that like what was because
that's the biggest that's what you that
was the time were you were you nervous
were you of course i was nervous but but
also i'd worked for wcw the ted turner
company for three years
and then i finally get to the
destination did you have a character
going on yeah i had it the character was
y2j because it was 1999. it was right
before y2k right uh
oh there you go jericho starts with jay
uh why
but chris jericho's not your given name
why why did you change it uh well chris
irvin isn't really a great show business
wrestling name christopher and um
originally i wanted to be uh the name
that i had chosen for myself
was jack action
jack action yes so i was it's a little
pony i'm gonna say it's a little gay
pony yeah it's a little bit of like a
some kind of a machine that you would
find at the hollywood hustler store down
there
the jack action machine don't use the
jack action for very long
don't turn it to top speed yeah one
minute that's the mid speed that's all
you can take but then i was writing it
on this book that i i don't know i was
keeping notes or whatever it was and
like one of the guys i was training with
was like uh
you know practicing my autograph and
he's like what is that jack action is
that gonna be your name i'm like i don't
know because that's a stupid name it's a
dumb name like of course it's not going
to be my name
i'm not going to use jack action i'm
like [ __ ] what am i going to do so his
name was joe diesel
but i needed a name so there was uh
there's this power metal band from
germany called
halloween yep yeah uh halloween and they
had a record called walls of jericho and
i had the cassette sitting on the front
uh seat of my car and i was like ah
chris jericho that's what i'll be ta-da
so i've been chris jericho from my very
first match so it wasn't anything that
you had a deep significance or like a
wow dover saw the walls of jericho by
hello
it could have been chris halloween or
chris walls
it's like that scene in brady bunch
where she's like yeah i'm going on a
date where marsha's like jan is like i'm
going up george george glass yeah
totally george george glass that's
exactly what it is not to compare you to
uh jan brady or uh sure that's the first
time that's happened that could be yeah
that was my other choice jack action and
then jack brady yeah no it's gonna be
yon brady not bad
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
you don't still wrestle anymore yeah i
still do but uh uh so there's a new
company that's just started up uh owned
by the family that owns the jacksonville
jaguars oh khan family it's called aew
and we just had our first show at the
mgm grand in las vegas we start in the
fall on tnt network um it's a great time
for
an alternative to the wwe um because i
think people are waiting for something
because w's such a monopoly right now
people are looking for
another option
and it's called what aew all elite
wrestling because we've never had a
company
really challenge wwe in 20 years because
20 years ago the wwe bought wcw the
turner company so they've had the
monopoly for the last 20 years well now
it's changed to where now there's
actually somebody that might be able to
keep
aew they're billing it i'm reading here
as the usfl of the wrestling world i'm
just kidding
i was like i'm not sure about this but
that must have been a big draw huge for
them to get you to attract you to come
to there it was it's it's they needed a
bridge because they've got a lot of guys
that are super good but no one's really
heard of in the states they've honed
their craft worldwide they're all
american guys but they go to japan and
mexico japan mexico small companies in
the states but they've got huge fan
bases what is it like for you when you
go back to japan now are you still it's
great yeah i mean i just came back
to a week ago oh you go over there
fairly often uh yeah i've been uh
there's a company there called new japan
pro wrestling nude japanese nude not
nude yet they knew japan uh you just go
out there and uh it's in an apartment
and they film it and put it on i'm
listening yeah
so when you do y2j what is that how is
that character different so who you are
what the character was originally is i
always wanted to be
the uh ultimate rock and roll front man
that's right that was another dream in a
wrestling ring i see okay so take the
qualities of paul stanley and david roth
and freddie mercury and make chat funko
art garfunkel amazing amazing uh
dynamic performers david crosby yeah
actually all crosby stills nation and
actually that's what inspired young's
got too much charisma for that but
young's perfect for a he could have a
fellow winnipegger oh yeah yeah he's got
a it's funny my my brother said
something about him the other day
because he's in this documentary echoes
in the camera of course
you guys are all those guys early
footage of him when he was in buffalo
springfield which i had never really
seen and he said
neil young was
weirder when he was younger
than he is he neil young seemed older
when he was younger yeah yeah yeah he
had such an interesting yeah there are
certain guys that you look at that were
old looking when they were young yes
yeah i was just watching the thing the
other day and wilford brimley is in it
oh like oh he looks exactly the same
today they do that he's like 40 then yes
which is why you're like wait wilfred
brimley's still alive that's amazing but
you're sure he's been that age for never
changed morgan freeman morgan freeman
has always been old i remember morgan
freeman in the 70s on the electric
company yes as an old man easy reader
yeah as an old young man as an old man
reading books but he was cool yeah kind
of like now yeah he's always been cool
samuel jackson looks the same exactly so
like it's cool when they get older when
they're younger like man these poor guys
never never were young well it's great
for them when they get older because
they just get it's like well nothing
never changes doesn't change that much
you look great
when you're 70. when you were 30 it's
like man that guy looks old you see
shirley temple it's like you're an old
woman he grew into his age
shirley temple i don't know where that
came from that's great i'm trying to
keep the show young
well sure and there's nothing more young
and fresh than shirley temple a teen a
child actress from the 30s yeah the kids
love it did you ever drink shirley
temples in your oh [ __ ] is that a thing
oh surely yeah surely i love i drank
shirley temples uh until i was too old
to be drinking surely i still like
shirley temperatures last night oh
they're great
grenadine and seven up seven up or
grenadine ginger ale if you get the
right you know was your little cocktail
when you were a kid dad would have a
whiskey sour and totally mom would have
uh gimlet vodka gimlet and the kid would
have a shirley temple well that's a
hardcore fan that's a that's a winnipeg
family we just had uh we there's a
little wine and um and a beer my dad
loves beer uh and and the marciano
cherry oh yeah yeah
what do you drink now yeah i just uh so
i don't drink anything just i just drink
vodka just vodka about five years ago or
something i noticed you just poured some
water when chris came to the studio yeah
i was guessing you want a coffee said no
no i'm good with with vodka with with
what was just with
water and you're doing the quote yeah
air quoting water and there's water you
know
it's five o'clock somewhere justin
classic jericho
um yeah just vodka i went on this thing
about six years ago called the caveman
diet which has since been named the keto
diet oh yeah and that means you just all
you eat is what comes from the land you
you seem like you would be on a caveman
diet well i'm not any it's hard it's
hard to stay on i stayed on it for about
a year and change and i was super ripped
but man all you're eating is like
eggs and meat and nuts and eggs and meat
and nuts yeah eggs and meat and nuts and
that's about exactly meat well yeah yeah
and you know like uh dinosaur eggs as
well willy mammoth yeah and then and
then uh
and then fuzzies or nuts
what a dumb thing to say well
a mammal were you around when they were
there he was a mammal well that's what
they say as far as you know
i knew it was coming sooner or later um
how has the character changed that right
i mean so the y2j was like what's the so
ytj was so my point was yjj was like a
rock and roll star
in the ring and very loud and abrasive
and insulting and that sort of thing but
i don't do that character anymore
because it'd be like
you know it would be like a nostalgia
act like how would you
as that character how would you confront
me if i said um let's say i didn't put
the the you wanted coffee with it it's
hard it's hard to do that you know what
i mean because you got to be in
character right you know what i'm saying
like
everyone like it's funny like when i did
uh
when i did dancing with the stars they
do
a beginning montage
like it's just cheech marin and he would
do like something like wacky like wakka
wakka yeah so i they wanted me to like
okay so so we're filming your opening uh
scene for the opening of the show
montage rip your shirt off and scream in
the camera
and i'm like i just asked me to do that
on access
right yeah exactly earlier
hey lopez back off um so what do you say
to that are you like i'd say i've never
ripped my shirt off and screamed in the
camera ever
and they're kind of like well
you're already worried it's like yeah
isn't that what you guys do i'm like
well if i was hulk hogan maybe but i'm
not and that's not my thing and they
were so kind of disappointed listen
i'm like well then what are you gonna do
i'm like just [ __ ] turn the camera on
yeah
let me do my thing and you guys will
you'll love it i promise and that's
that's you know that's what i said what
what did you enter i think i just like
grabbed the camera and shook it
did a little you know smile or whatever
i did like they loved it but
yeah exactly like a little one billion
dollars yeah i have a secret yeah i
worked for nude japan
um
call back but it was one of those things
where it's like
you can get into it in the moment but
when people would say like okay like
it's be like right you can't just tell a
comedian like just say something funny
oh i know do something funny oh god you
know what i mean yeah i do do george
harrison right now do you george
harrison well if you want me to that was
out of nowhere though yeah like okay
we've seen the land in the mccarty but
who's ever done a georgetown that was
the challenge that was tough because and
i learned about that job uh chris's
referencing movie called walk hard yes
they played the beatles yeah it was the
best professional day of my life i think
it was and and the most pressure too
because there's no
paul rudd was john lennon jack black was
paul mccartney you were george and jason
schwartzman was ringo right yes i love
that scene i watched it probably a
hundred times god i i so judd apatow who
produced it asked me to do that a couple
with like a couple days before we were
to shoot and um
i
the day before we were shooting paul
rudd and i i met up with him in his
hotel room and we were just
pouring over footage of the beatles we
were watching as many documentaries as
we could see and um trying to get the
different and i i realized there were a
lot of different nuances to each of the
four of them and um
like john john was very nasally yeah
something he kind of spoke through his
and and ringo was to do ringo you have
to kind of push your head back and
ringo's got him back yeah like he was
that's good you have to i'm like
peace and love please and love
ears a bit lower voice
and and paul was more sings on you there
was more of a more of a rhythm to his
ups and downs and you know
and i was like what is george is
there was something more neutral about
george there was there was but it was
still that liverpool i love accents and
i loved getting that down so paul and i
are
cramming you know and we're trying to
get the each uh each of the beatles down
and uh and he's and schwartzman called
jason schwartzman who's as he said
playing ringo and and he said uh i and
paul got off the phone with him and he
said oh that was chase and like he's we
were just talking about how nervous we
are about
you know about playing the beatles and i
said yeah we were we were we were really
it was like a lot of pressure and as i
was leaving paul's room he said you know
i shouldn't tell you this i said i
wonder how jack black feels i wonder if
he's nervous and paul goes i shouldn't
tell you this but i ran into jack a
couple days earlier and i asked him that
question i said are you nervous we're
playing the beatles and check us no dude
not at all dude i got it i got it down
and and paul goes how what what
how did you do he goes dude watch hard
day's night that's all you do just watch
hard day's night it's good to go so we
were like oh great jack blocks
that's a great jack black talking about
learning
well the next day we show up and and and
the first moment of rehearsal we start
reading it
jack jack's got the first line as paul
and he goes hey paul mccartney
i mean the bell toll and we were like i
looked at paul and you're like what the
[ __ ]
but it was ended up being so much fun
here that's what i love about it is that
you three guys
uh meaning you and paul and and
schwartzman
studied and you can tell and you're
really really we're gonna jack just came
in and just did the most generic shitty
mccartney yeah i'm the funny whimsical
guy that's what i do and it's like it's
so bad but you can just tell you just
showed up but the joke was that like
we're clearly doing this like cameo it's
clearly like these guys and and
especially with jack because he's so
famous yeah yeah yeah yeah right so it
really worked it was and there was a
lesson in like this maybe maybe you
don't try so hard just do it yeah
exactly uh yeah so point b so the y2j
thing that was one character and then i
evolved into
after a few years i left for bit when i
came back i was kind of doing the same
character and it felt like nostalgia
like time has passed this character by
and i didn't know
how to re revamp it huh and i was
watching the movie no country for old
men
and that's the one that javier bardem
plays uh anton sugar yeah i love that
hairstyle that's kind of my natural
hairstyle so good yeah it's so good i
wish i could grow a bowl cut like that
but i could do kind of his character
which was
very quiet and very uh matter-of-fact
like i'm going to kill you if you know
heads or tails and i thought what a
psycho
and not much more intimidating yes and
not doing the typical rip your shirt off
and yell at the camera but making people
listen to what i say and so i kind of
morphed into this character and i
remember when i was doing it because it
was a real evil bad guy and it was it
worked like it was probably one of the
last
bad guys that was getting attacked on
the street for real this character
character yeah
and
i remember talking in the middle of an
arena in front of you know ten thousand
people but almost whispering were i
could remember people people going we
can't hear you we can't unlike exactly
so shut the [ __ ] up it takes real that
takes so much more confidence and yes
less fear i mean you really need to lack
fear yes and
once people started like
you know we can't hear you ha ha doing
whatever [ __ ] they're doing and actually
tuning in to what i was saying listening
yeah exact listening i hooked them
and once i hooked them i had them and i
played that character for about
two and a half years which is very rare
for a bad guy to have that kind of light
we call it for that long because here's
why you'll understand this every bad guy
not just in wrestling but in movies
always ends up turning into a good guy
the terminator hannibal lecter freddy
krueger uh if heath ledger played the
joker again if he hadn't passed away it
would have been a huge babyface good guy
because he's so entertaining that's
right people forget hannibal lecter is
technically a good i mean a good guy but
like he helps cleary starlight just but
my point is
he's so entertaining and interesting yes
that you're much like even when he's
killing the cops like freddy krueger you
want to see freddie kill all the
teenagers because they're idiots you
know
like you know terminator 2
are like in the terminator watch the
first terminator turmeria is a psycho
he's killing yeah kids and people in a
club and then terminator 2
everyone loves you because he's so
entertaining you can imitate him you can
dress up as them for halloween
it's easier to make people hate you than
it is to make them love you in wrestling
but once they start hating you it's hard
to make them keep hating you right
because they want to start loving you so
if you because yeah yeah yeah do you
think it's difficult for the fans to
pivot from here's y2j this is the guy
that i've gotten to know and now he's
being like a dick it's like a
soft-spoken like bag yes but you changed
everything i started wearing suits to
the ring i changed from long pants to
short tights it's like long pants to
short tight yeah like long
long i guess you would call them trunks
trousers like
not trousers slacks
i need some trousers
yeah um so the long ones are called
tights oh okay the short ones are called
trunks okay so i switched from tights to
to the trunks like because all these
things that you do subtly makes people
realize that you're a different guy now
you know what i mean like when kiss took
off the makeup there was no doubt like
they don't wear makeup anymore like what
do you mean this is different chris do
you have to then spin uh a whole
narrative about why you changed like is
there anything there's a narrative but
it's not much um i can't remember what
the reason was for that uh
whatever you know he developed black
people
something along those lines i think is i
ate a bad grape and i
screwed up my mind or something like do
you wear a cup in this no no no it's an
interesting question whoa i think i
might have been i think i might have
asked that very same question on my
first day of wrestling school not bad i
couldn't believe that you didn't work
especially being a hockey player you
wear we call them chocks yeah yeah you
showed me
a jock strap yeah put your jack on it
yeah well this feels like my first day
of wrestling school it kind of is yeah
yeah because i know so that's what's
it's really interesting talking because
i i do know i have so little and i like
that too because
to learn things
even it's just a little bit about
something you've never
known before absolutely i mean and your
podcast we should mention uh people
probably know it's talk is jericho and
it's been you've been doing it we were
talking about kevin smith kevin's done
his for 12 years but you're
you've been doing it for about you said
six six years i think we're getting
close to 600 episodes that's back when
they're only 300 000 podcasts that's
about right dude it was 2013 i started
it and why did you start uh for the same
reason why we're doing this right now
i've always been very curious yeah i
like good conversations i'll even tell
you this this is not uh bearing anybody
because it's the god's honest truth the
worst guest i ever had was mike tyson um
and i've known mike i worked with mike
we did we were tag team partners in the
wwe one time oh my knocking me out quote
unquote wow and he was promoting his
one-man show and they came to me my
producer i was in hawaii i got up at
like 3 a.m drove to some
silence of the lamb's guy's house where
he had a little studio like sure i got a
studio
yeah
go ahead are you just going to be
wrestling each other it sounds fun put
lotion on before you do it it puts the
recorder in the basket
so i'm sitting there and it's it was
pretty much like that and this [ __ ]
guy would not talk about tyson like he's
giving me one word answers one sentence
answered i'm like
you do know you're you're doing a
podcast that you requested to be on dude
we were done in four minutes and then
like what am i gonna do
and then after poking and plotting a
little liar i said you know what if he's
not gonna talk i still need a show i'm
just gonna talk and you can listen and
that's what i did and did he ever say
hey look i'm sorry no maybe he was in a
bad mood maybe i just saw him a couple
weeks ago and talked to him for a bit
and that's how he talks now he's just
very hard to have a conversation with
you know and yet the irony is he's
promoting a one-man show
talking like i said like what's like i'm
saying okay well one minute should he
must have a couple stories well what
kind of stories you tell they just think
boxing stories and
i'm like okay i know he i know he breeds
pigeons what if nothing else we'll talk
about pigeons
30 seconds yeah i get some pigeons on my
roof and i feed them and
so you still have them yeah they're not
going anywhere
dead air dead air dead air i'm like holy
[ __ ] man
life could be a dream sweetheart
i know there's a i know there's
a lot of feuds in wrestling they're
um that that's one of the things that i
kind of was able to gather the stories
there that's those are telling stories
right how did those develop you should
you determine them yeah i mean once
again it's like i said when i said
earlier it's like a a live shakespearean
morality play i mean you have it's
called a booking committee they kind of
put together the matches and the
storylines of what we have
i come up with a lot of my own story
lines because of my experience level
when you're working with a whole bunch
of new guys if i don't play the bad guy
people won't pay attention to them
because they know chris jericho and they
just want to cheer for chris jericho we
love jericho
you probably think i've done the other
thing i did that i did it well like i
said listen if you needed me to be a
good guy i can do that too you can do
either one but for my position and with
the fact there's so many guys that
nobody knows like i said it's a lot
easier to make people hate you than to
make them like you at first if i'm in
there
with a young guy who's the baby face the
good guy i can make them hate me which
by proxy makes people like them does
that ever bleed into real life like do
you ever do a show afterwards they're
like hey dude you got a little too
aggressive you like not really i mean
you're
at that level you're professionally
professional i mean once in a while you
hit a live round and once in a while
somebody gets hurt or you might you know
knock somebody's nose or they start
bleeding or whatever it may be but yeah
we're all pretty professional but still
[ __ ] happens man and some of that stuff
looks fair i mean i see it
you do like especially with my style at
this point in time it's pretty strong
style you're fighting each other not
hurting but flooding somebody's nose
to get the reaction that you want so
that's when you're working with someone
that you know feels the same way yeah he
can do that when you say bloody nose
like that there's all fake blood or no
no bloody nose really yeah yeah if you
know where to hit somebody you can make
them bleed most of the time if you get
anybody in the nose it's going to make
them bleed i should point out that to
our listeners that you you just said
that with a big smile on your face
yeah of course i've been wrestling for
30 years i've got to be some kind of
psycho right you know i'm not totally
normal all right right okay okay
moving on um
question let me show you how it works
in order to maintain your physique
because you're a very you're a muscular
person what is that like how do you have
to train all the time no at this point i
don't really go to the gym so much it's
more yoga yoga stuff i do a lot of mma
training okay um like boxing type stuff
so so that's to to maintain a cut
physically yeah and that that's kind of
the workouts that i do now you know
getting in there and how much you bench
and that sort of thing it's the not that
i'm 48 years old so you don't you you
have to
evolve your training
as you get older and you're playing like
you said a different character you're
playing like a bad guy you don't
necessarily have to yeah i'm still in
shape right yeah
well even if i wasn't wrestling you
would i would still do this because you
know when you're in your 20s or whatever
you try and lift as heavy as you can
because that's just more of what a young
kid does yeah yeah
as you get older it's not about that and
plus your joints feel differently and
that sort of thing there's another thing
that i want to touch on briefly before
you go uh you another thing you
mentioned was was you wanted to be a
rock star yeah and that you also realize
that dream uh you're in a band called
fozzie it started and i learned this
from your podcast it started as a as
nazi osbourne
it's an 80s metal cover band yeah fozzy
osbourne and it was just um
a bunch of guys that i met that lived in
atlanta that were in a band called stuck
mojo that was really popular at the time
they had a cover band and i was looking
to put together a band at that point in
time and you already had a following as
a wrestler i did i was in band since i
was 13 all the way up until 20. and then
wrestling kind of became popular i still
recorded demos and played but i wanted
to form a band and start playing and
just you know typical fate just met
these guys and that's kind of how it all
started and how do you juggle the two
worlds you don't juggle the more than
two words i mean i did juggle for a
point in time but 2010 fawzi became the
priority when i started kind of
weaning myself out of full-time
wrestling and that's when we really said
let's give this a go and see how far we
can get with it so um we did really well
and our last record judas came out in
2017 and that was uh that was really big
for us it gave us a top five hit oh wow
on rock radio and
once you get the elusive hit it takes
you to a different different plane of
existence you know what i mean so yeah
yeah even to the point where in
september we're opening for iron maiden
here in la at the bank of california
stadium i think where the galaxy plays
so we're getting more of those type of
gigs do you think about legacy i mean in
terms of being remembered do you ever
think about the music versus the
wrestling in in those i think it's a
combination both because what i've
really been focusing on over the last 10
years
knowing that
i don't want to wrestle forever i can't
wrestle forever
but you know mick jagger can still play
with the stones at 77.
it's more the the jericho brand yeah you
know entertainment that's why podcasting
is important and then doing the more
more acting and the band and that sort
of stuff that's something i can do for
the rest of my life yeah so it's more
about
and i have a great fan base that follows
me pretty much do whatever project i do
yes i don't do things just for money and
i don't do things that i feel
like i was offered a celebrity magician
and there's this big
uh uh time frame where they're doing a
celebrity high diving these are real
things uh there's a celebrity uh
diving yeah remember i think louis
armstrong louis armstrong hi that i'd
see
a lot the guy that i think he was
what a wonderful diving board
um one of the guys i can't remember
there was a celebrity driving the show
maybe that was it yeah walking on on the
underwater moon um but yeah so i mean
yeah i just stay away from that type of
stuff right um
but i try and pick things that i find
interesting which i think my
uh my fan base will find interesting as
well it's celebrity colonoscopy well i
mean yeah celebrity butcher shop
i mean literally they went through this
physics there was like my friend's
vanilla vanilla ice and he does all of
them celebrities i just i'm sorry it's
hard to say my friends vanilla ice and
then have the listener move on i just
need to take a second and digest that
just a killer great guy super friendly
rob rob rob van winkle yeah uh just ran
into him on a show once but he's he's
experienced fame since he was a kid
because his father was rip right
i think it was yeah but but he used to
sleep a lot so he kind of he missed a
lot of this we can cut this out no sorry
don't cut it out keep it going and leave
it in there so i've heard he's actually
a really great guy and and he is he's
always good on in those adam sandler
movies but that's the thing because
because i think there was a certain part
for him and then adam loved him so much
they put him in everything yeah he's
that type of guy but my point is that he
does he did everything like celebrity uh
bull riding like whatever it is
celebrity sword swallowing he's up for
it yeah and that's one side of the coin
and i try and stay away from that as
much as i can so when i get to the point
where my career is just done just dude
then i'll be on everything cash in your
chips yeah exactly yeah celebrity chip
cash in celebrities we're playing in
reno you know playing the shitty wooden
nickel poker whatever it may be
you know celebrity barium enema
um
yeah well these are quick and i know you
have to go yeah um speaking of animals
um
it's about time but 70 minutes in we're
finally getting to animals i know right
this is the good stuff um do you think
about the afterlife this isn't a quick
question but uh i know that you yeah i
do you were raised
raised in the church but more uh over
the years kind of got into christianity
i go through phases which is bad but
there was a point in time where i was
super into god because of christian
heavy metal like i really got into
striper and these type of bands uh you
know what's interesting sometimes i'll
be listening to the radio on a road trip
and i'm like this is a cool song this is
a really good song it's like
and that's what jesus wants us to and i
really realize oh it's a christmas
christian
i i don't seek out christian music but i
find myself i mean it finds you it finds
me yeah
and that that really was a time in the
late 80s when christian heavy metal was
really a a big sub genre of heavy metal
um but yeah the afterlife is is weird to
me because i'll think about it sometimes
and really start freaking myself out
like of course you know like what
happens like
when somebody i know dies or something
happens and you start thinking like oh
yeah well the afterlife okay it's cool
but then really envision like what
happens when you die yeah it's really
really intimidating i'm sorry you say
like i have a limited amount of time
left in this podcast and i i'm sorry to
ask you that question because you're
right i mean if you
if that's the thing nobody knows that's
why i'm so curious about what other
people think about it and i think you
know when people say
well there's nothing i'm like i don't
buy that like you just so you're just
done like you just your candle snuffs
out and then like see you later buddy
like like i i don't i don't know what if
that's the thing what a shitty ending
i've i've spent so many hours at night
uh not being able to sleep because of
that and i know people they're the same
and like honestly i i kind of am one of
them well that's why i sometimes i i
really admire and i i'm sometimes
jealous of people who are very religious
because i think because they have it
they have a
piece figured out they have these peace
of mind you mentioned we were talked
about george harrison and we can get it
like i said we'll do more of these in
the future because there's a lot of yeah
i love that um i mean to me george
harrison is is the coolest beatle he's
the beatle that if the beatles are
having a party
i would walk in and go like does anyone
know where george is at like where is he
at i completely and did you ever see
that um
amazing
it's called we should tell people living
in the material world yeah it's about a
four-hour documentary in georgia
you need to watch it like even if you're
not a beatles fan there's a footage of
him and he was so funny i actually know
his son a little bit danny danny right
he is like that he's seen just a
spitting image right basically it's like
bizarre but he says in there um when
he's talking about dying and it's like
what
what do you have to live for and he's
like well um
i got a son so i want to stick around
for him as long as i can but
other than that and then he looks at the
camera and starts laughing like like
there's nothing like take me away i'm
ready let's go find out what's going on
in the next i remember that he seemed
very ready to move on yeah
another
probably the reason i admire him the
most of all the reasons to admire that
guy yeah and funny i really value humor
he was uh very funny you know very much
that monty python style of humor but and
i wish i really admired that i wish i i
could adopt that mindset that like this
is just uh i think you have to find
something though you know what i mean
whether because he was really into you
know the hindu religion and that sort of
thing and so maybe
and religion is not a great word for me
but maybe maybe the spiritual side is
where you want to go with it yeah let's
say that this is all there is right
let's say that this is that like you
said it's a candle being snuffed
snuffed out isn't it at least more
exciting to think about the i mean
that's what if then that's what we have
and if you're on your deathbed and they
say okay well pray to god and ask for
forgiveness or just die
i would pray to god and ask for
forgiveness
even if i'd never heard of god just
because what what if it's true i'd pray
to vanilla ice like what if it's what if
there's a demon or what if there's an
alien or what if there's a lake monster
like what if that was the that was the
the basis of this blaze pascal was this
philosopher who said that his his
it's called pascal's wager where he said
you live your life as though there is a
god and an afterlife and if at the end
it turns out not to be you've lived in a
good light yeah you lived a good deal
like you were good to people that's
right um so i think about pascal's wager
a lot uh
okay these are quick i'm sorry uh your
most commonly used emoji
your go-to i'm texting my daughter
a big one for me is the winking eye
combined with the thumbs up okay
you're winking and your thumbs are up
yeah yeah playful that's a good one um
if you could be a professional athlete
outside of wrestling
probably hockey because that's the other
sport that i have any interest in at all
football now too because my wife is
super into football but what's her team
minnesota vikings oh jess she's from
minnesota but yeah i mean i never really
got into sports so much but probably
hockey hockey and your team at high is
still the rangers jets want to pick jets
um
favorite movie of all time
uh
big lebowskis up there i mean i think
that encapsulates it's just god one
preposterous situation after another
great dialogue yes uh i just i'm going
through my son discovered tarantino so
we're going through the tarantino
catalogue how fun to get to re-watch all
those yeah with through his eyes i mean
yeah pulp fiction when we're watching it
and you know the bruce willis goes
downstairs and marcellus wallace is
getting plowed up the ass
by the guy i mean
seeing a 15 year old kid watching that
and he's like
what the hell is going on like talk
about a plot twist yeah how do you
describe that to your side you just go
away well son you should know that
sometimes people get plowed up the ass
don't go to pawn shops um but that's
actually white supremacism yeah that's a
great movie and then i just saw uh on
father's day we went to see jaws in the
theater
which i'd never seen in the theater on
the big screen i mean i've seen it
obviously 50 times but maybe the best
movie ever made yeah you forget you
forget how good the you know what i
noticed about those those spielberg
movies the the background actors there's
such good that there's so much
so much going on going on yeah even
those little parts it's so thoughtful um
i had a funny big lebowski moment the
other day i was i had ash i was cleaning
out my grill and um and i i was going to
spread some of the ashes on on my garden
for fertilizer and a gust of wind picked
up it just covered me and i was like ah
this is i deserve that um
donnie you're i hesitate to ask this i
think i hope i know the answer your
favorite muppet
um i always liked the swedish chef yes
he was great and then
and then it was his little beaker beaker
was bunsen honeydew's
assistant i love both of those uh
waldorf and uh
sure [ __ ] yeah the old man yeah
bearing everything it's about time
somebody got plowed up the ass in this
tarantino movie yeah maybe it'll be you
next round
uh i'm surprising to say fozzie bear
uh yeah considering school but we didn't
you know we didn't name the band after
the only reason why we did that was
because
i don't really know why they had fozzie
osborne going before i met them but oh
it's like foe ozzy i think it was kind
of like just combining fozzie with and i
remember that logo used to be fozzie
bear biting off a bat oh really but i
think because so many times over the
years people have gone so did you name
fozzie after the muppet i'm like no i'm
sorry it's just the name so maybe fozzie
bear has now become my enemies
yeah yeah you gotta you bristled a
little bit when i mentioned fuzzy bear
what the [ __ ]
no no is that a cut down no no we'll go
with swedish chef yeah i like him really
if you have dinner with three people
dead or alive whom you've never met
um geez that's a hard one because i mean
i'm a huge beatles fanatic yeah but i
mean i i would have to go through rock
through through rock and roll i would
say so let's say george harrison
let's say bon scott ac dc singer and
then let's say uh cliff burton the bass
player from metallica who died in the
bus crash that's just from the rock and
roll side of things
huge into all those bands um if you you
could be one non-human animal
uh what would it be what animal do you
know how people are like that's my
spirit animal who do you identify with
always wanted to be turned into a walrus
and you have done that so i'm very
jealous of you okay um you shouldn't be
but
um
spirit animal man i i think i mean you
know you got a tattoo i see you have a
lot of tattoos if you had one if you
were like how did you get an animal that
represents i really
dig dogs like i just think you know it's
kind of maybe a little cliched but
i mean
i never had dogs growing up but i have
them now and i just think the best
uh
what do you have therapy
for a shitty day is just the dog just
come up with a big dumb dog coming and
licking your face yeah you know i have
two labs a golden lab and a chalk a
silver lab a chocolate lab and a silver
lab and then i got a chihuahua and i got
a pomeranian
so yeah man but that's crazy about
pomeranians but the other ones yeah well
pomeranian was a rescue dog that's a
long story okay um uh and even quicker
uh
dogs cats you mentioned dogs um uh
beetle stones i know this one uh it's
hard to say because we talk about this
quite a bit with my little circle of
friends and
i mean the beatles
the most genius band of all time but the
longevity of the stones and the quality
of the live performances and so this is
something somebody pointed out to me
that was like oh you got me is that the
stones can play any one of their songs
live
the beatles
not that they couldn't but they didn't
and if they did they would have to have
extra musicians like the stones dude
revolution number nine would be hard to
play yeah it would be hard to play live
but you could have the dj just you know
right spinning
turn me on dead man turn me undead man
isn't it amazing to think that like it's
not only that that's such a weird and
dumb song but like that it's on the
white album well the thing is though
loots that album okay but here's the
thing there's a whole style of music now
that's like that i can't remember what
it's called avant-garde music or
whatever yes and i know it was yoko's
influence but they started it even even
for that that's true genre that's true
they started that as well so
even though it's kind of just noise
there is like what was she used to be
married to louis or she was married to
lou reed is it laureate lori anderson oh
okay she that's her music that she makes
the beatles were the first so they even
invented that stuff you're a real glass
half-full kind of guy huh try to be yeah
yeah you mentioned jaded people and you
are anything but i wrote a book uh the
last book you wrote was called no is a
four-letter word how i failed spelling
but succeeded in life oh i thought it
was noah as a four letter
noah's ark and it's all about you know
get ready for the flood it's a real
post-apocalyptic feel-good book
the point being is that no is a dirty
word to the point where people accept it
instead of uh
it's like for example instead of looking
for ways to make something happen
they'll accept the reasons why you can't
make it happen and just settle for that
i never settle for anything if you want
to do something if you want to make
something happen you can do it it might
be more work but you can always do it
you can always make it happen
uh fast time is the ridgemont high
and i call it the mike demon principle
where he's talking to rat and he goes uh
wherever you are
act like this is the place to be yeah
yeah that's true look at this oh that's
right isn't this great like that if you
have that attitude about everything you
do in life your life will be so much
better and the beast and play b side of
led zeppelin yeah
where they actually screwed up and
played cashmere with some physical
graffiti
that's a whole other movie trivia wow
you are filled with stuff i i can't wait
to talk to you again
on your show it's talk is jericho and um
and and what's and how what's next what
do people see um talk is jericho's twice
a week that's on westwood one itunes and
spotify and all that stuff and then uh
our next show for all aew is in chicago
at the uh sears center uh august 31st
august 31st and uh what else that's
hopefully kevin's movie i can't wait to
kevin's movie this one is called kilroy
was here and then jay and santa bob
reboot were you in the gym yes yeah yes
so see us both
yeah we'll i'll see it at the premiere
that might not happen but we'll have a
premiere at kevin's house and yeah yeah
we'll have a 17 hour
house uh this has been thanks chris this
has been really thank you brother great
to meet you thank you more to come
[Music]
so that happened eh terrible
you know some canadian accents somebody
on instagram said uh said that that uh
my canadians and she was
nice about it but she just said you have
a terrible canadian wow
i used to think it was good i told her
to listen to that i said you know we
have two canadians coming up this before
kobe and uh and we did we did two
canadians in a row and that's right
jericho's is very strong a boot abood
and
you know i always think that canadians
say that word more often but i think
it's just uh you know my ears or do you
hear it i hear it more yeah well
jericho's is very strong well talk is
jericho you know what they say you know
the old expression that's true
that's true
uh it was really clear to me that he's
had a podcast for six years because he's
very good at taking control
of the conversation and he did that from
the start oh yeah and did you notice
that whenever things would go off a
little bit on a tangent he would always
bring it back by saying okay the point
being yeah and he was centered and i
thought that was really impressive yeah
he had he had a lot of control yeah of
the interview
yes i mean it's not that you didn't have
control and notice that sometimes he
i'll strong-arm you which i need i mean
that's uh i have a tendency to go off
the rails a little bit and
go down these little you know
tributaries like i'm doing noticed yeah
uh he talks about
um meeting me and thinking uh first that
i was you and it sort of helped him
break the ice which
i was sort of offended by yeah only
because
i felt like he was using me as a
friendship fluffer for you
he's kind of like warming up with me
and he's got it his theory of meeting
people which i kind of sounds nice is
you know when you meet people you should
be nice to everybody because you never
know who you're meeting like implying
you could be meeting some big record
executive or something i'm the political
figure right but then the downside of
that is oh you're only being nice to me
because you think i might
be a big exactly one day i mean that's
the implication is that like
you there is um how would you say that
you have to
[Music]
you have to give value to people that
may not necessarily in your eyes have
value yet exactly like that everyone's
blindly giving value exactly but maybe i
misinterpreted that may i bet if he had
to defend himself he would say oh no
it's not because i thought you might be
a music executive it's because you
should be nice to everybody i i i give
them the benefit of the dad seems like a
really nice guy but i will also say when
he met you uh he when he met me and i
went on about how nice he was he and he
admits this he thought i was you
yes it's a christian and i look a lot
alike and and uh if you
follow us on instagram you'll know but
uh he thought i was you so that's
another like wait a minute oh so you
wouldn't have been
as nice i was so impressed and praised
i was impressed that he was nice to
everyone he was i mean i gotta say
regardless of where it comes from yeah
he is very present and he looks you in
the eye yeah direct and
he he has real authority about him well
i mean talk is jerry that's true you
know what they say
he says that wrestling is acting and
that he
oh yeah he said that it's about 75
percent personality 25
uh physicality yeah which i thought was
interesting that is interesting because
he and i it makes sense that so many of
them i mean this is kind of duh but
that's so many transition into becoming
actors then uh but then you when you
think about that 25
see what i didn't know is he started
talking about bloodying noses and like i
didn't know that they were
i know that just threw that in there
yeah that consistently and the way he
said that to me when he looked at me and
he's like he said first when the way he
said oh if i could bloody your nose i
like i forget how he said it like i i
know how to bloody you know he was sort
of studying my face as he said it like
he was
sizing up probably thinking how easy it
would be might do it but he could flick
yourself
probably oh my god
i'm like uh
i'm just
so feeble compared to he really is like
a powerful i'm not sure i agree with the
wrestling's acting thing i know there's
there's obviously there's a performance
element to it but i think it's
you know when you're an actor maybe i'm
giving actors too much credit but the
idea is you're inhabiting a character
whereas
and hopefully believably whereas in
wrestling it's it's so much of it is
just like this bravado you know this
like but i don't think you see emoting
it's emoting more than acting i would i
would say but maybe i just haven't seen
enough wrestling maybe you haven't seen
because the way he i mean i i would
agree with you if it weren't for
uh that other
character that he played the like
the more the like the villain oh the
royal
yeah but he talks about he see he lumps
the reason i say that is because he
lumped acting music wrestling into one
thing and he said in all those things
it's about captivating a crowd
and to some degree he's right i think
with all those things but with wrestling
it's really about captivating a crowd
whereas in acting unless you're doing a
play obviously there's an element of
that but
you're not you shouldn't be conscious of
the audience no there's when you're an
actor no i think you have to use a
different part of your performance brain
right if that makes sense like i think
about like pt barnum or some carnival
barker who's like step right up this you
know there's a real element of acting
obviously in that there's in performance
um but that's probably closer to who
whatever or even like certain
politicians you know i mean certain
politicians employ that type of
charisma yeah yeah i mean or the
bachelor i mean you know not to mention
it
no mention the bachelor again but but
like a lot of those
contestants will call them uh
they're there's a huge performance
element
um sure i just it just depends i'm glad
you didn't draw that analogy with him to
him
yeah it was kind of just like a bachelor
contestant
you know there have been you would have
bloodied your nose
[Laughter]
casually that was the most chilling part
of that when he was studying my face and
like hey he said it so casually there
have been a lot of wrestlers on the
bachelor i don't know a lot but there
was definitely one one i found it so
remarkable
that
i mean i would say if i had to sum this
guy up
in one way i would say he's a guy who
as a child
wanted to be a professional wrestler and
a rock star yeah and he went out and did
both
and the drive and focus to accomplish
both of those things is incredible
especially since now i don't know his
music but as a
in terms of wrestling like it it he he
talks about his rise and how it makes
sense
but on a physical level and now i'm glad
he's not here to because he would bloody
my nose maybe for this but he doesn't
he's
impressive i mean he's bit but he's not
big
he admits that yeah he said he was under
so he was undersized i mean he was like
5 11 190 he he says that that's why he
couldn't break in right away because he
talks about all those guys the hulk
hogan's yeah when we were kids they were
all like six four six five so he had to
go to mexico and japan and yeah i mean
there's small countries
countries but i
i'm i think we're the same height i mean
jericho i think
i think we are and and i remember i
didn't want to labor this point even
though i probably brought it up too much
when i had met dave bautista a couple
weeks earlier
who was i i answered the door and
he answered he answered his door uh he
didn't come to my house unexpectedly i
came to his house with a friend
unexpectedly and he was so
massive he's like a wall of a human
being he's same with the rock they're
[ __ ] enormous he doesn't like when
people refer to wrestling as fake like i
did in the intro um i'm glad i didn't
say that in his presence when you he
thought you were me but
it's not fair to call it fake because it
is it's like it's okay that it's fake
it's it's a performance it's a
performance it's the word fake has real
negative connections i think it implies
that it's yeah at one point he he's
telling a story where he
you're not gonna remember this but he's
telling a story no one else is going to
notice this he's telling a story where
uh he was living in vancouver in a
one-bedroom apartment with two guys and
under your breath you go
like butt head
and he didn't catch it thank god
but i it was so funny to me
it's so subtle
you just go uh
harmony guys
three guys in one room
uh you say that i know exactly i
actually know exactly just because i
heard it i heard it back
that he said that his uh wrestling name
he wanted it to be jack action which you
say is a little gay porny i disagree i
think it's incredibly gay porny
jack action
that's the that's the gayest gay porn
name i've ever heard
that's the porniest gay porn they've
ever heard yeah that's why even if i
were a gay porn producer i'd be like oh
we should you know you might want to
find something a little bit more subtle
uh let me school marm you really quickly
it's maraschino cherry i believe not
marciano cherry i said
i think so rocky martial yeah we're
talking about shirley temples oh yeah
you're right when you were talking to
chris jericho about how much you enjoy
shirley temples
good move oh you mean
almost jack action he was what's a gay
or porn name than jack action i can't
think of one don baller
uh no jack action sack johnson that's
pretty gay
um
he was really proud at one point he made
justin long you know justin long is a
gay porn yeah i know
there's important for the listener i
think i was telling the listeners but i
was looking at you
uh yeah i know
um yeah just so just a little fyi
just in fact i almost didn't get to use
my name when i when i joined the screen
actors union because there was um
the justin long who is a porn star had
one
sag related credit so man you need two
um when you join the straight porn union
yeah
i i almost had to go by my middle
initial uh
justin jaylen and which my favorite
sorry this is not going to be but
michael j fox and it reminded me of how
michael chief who i looked up to who i
always wanted to be like michael j fox
uh had to use the initial j because
there was a michael fox
and uh his middle initial is a i believe
michael a5 that's right and so he
thought that sounded conceited so he
went with michael j fox anyway sorry um
i didn't think you would end up talking
about pascal's wager with chris jericho
that was nice shirley temples and
pascal's wager who knew who knew talk is
jericho though that's true i mean that's
why you know you never know what you're
going to
discuss because talk is so jericho
finally got really jericho finally he uh
he ended he ended the interview by
saying in in a very similar way as he
started it he said now this is the last
thing i'm going to say then i'm going to
leave which is very again controlled he
controlled the start he controlled the
end
and i think he controlled a lot of the
middle but i thought it was a really
even flowed conversation yeah
he's a really he's a good conversation
he really is and it was and it was it
turned out to be um
as interesting as i thought it might be
just because it was such a he has such a
different point of view because he does
such a different thing
and i actually really appreciate
wrestling a lot more now than i did um i
do too i hope you guys also found uh
something of
at least slight value in that or it
helped put you to sleep
uh however you're listening to this
we're just happy you're listening and um
uh we're gonna read a letter now before
we end the show uh which is our new
thing
um
and it's called so this is about to
happen oh no i just don't
that can't stick no no no this is from
uh so this is from celine
and celine gives her uh the emojis that
which i i really like a lot of these uh
celine says thanks for asking about
personal stories and how we make the
most out of life i'm a stay-at-home mom
of two little boys seven and three my
oldest is autistic
he's an awesome kid who loves mario and
star wars dark side please but has some
challenges that we try our best to work
through things are not always easy but
we make it work one day at a time i'm
about to be 40 and with old age
celine that can't be old age
uh she says she says i'm about to be 40
and with old age comes great wisdom
insert sarcastic emoji here
i think one of the ones with the tongue
sticking out on the googly eyes it's all
about the little things focus on the
positive and there's that quote that
really stuck with me and sums it all up
wherever you go no matter what the
weather always bring your own sunshine
and she goes on uh she's now
she wants to start a keto bakery ice
creamery uh but does not have the funds
and um i wish she had included a way for
people to maybe contribute to that but
uh i think she'll figure out a way
though yeah and she's bringing the
sunshine whatever whenever she opens up
this place uh funds or no funds yeah
sunshine is free yeah that's true oh wow
i like that thanks see that would be a
good last word yeah it'd be great wait
let's keep it as the last word for the
show
okay for this episode sounds good um
what'd you say again i forgot
sunshine is free something about that
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
thank you for listening to life is short
if you like the show please give us a
five star review despite my bad canadian
accent and tell your friends to
subscribe we're available on apple
podcast spotify google podcast and every
major listening app as well as
wondering.com life is short it's hosted
by me justin long produced by christian
long and megan monaco our senior
producers michelle lands engineers
marcelino villapando executive produced
by marshall louis and ernan lopez for
wondering
[Music]
so stay tuned till the end of the
episode for a preview of bachelor happy
hour with rachel and ali and don't
forget to subscribe to bachelor happy
hour on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you're listening to this right
now
um
yeah i just i guess i just
but see this john cena guy looks like
he's playing a suburban dad yeah who
looks like he's
he looks like he's playing like a rick
moranis character like yeah
and you could tell he like
lost weight yeah he looks like he's like
weird he's only strong but he's still
like he's like a strong guy
yeah he still looks like a
muscular like a monster
he looks like a monster
yeah
any if a dad walked up to a couple of
kids like that who were like and it's
all about how like the kids are kind of
like dominant and like throwing a sex
party and
and he's supposed to he looked like he
was supposed to be like kind of
intimidated by them that's what that
movie was about yeah it's called cockpit
sex part i think so it's called [ __ ]
blockers
it's called blockers but what was going
on
um yeah but that doesn't mean they're
having a sex parties
don't you didn't you hear that in the
trailer like no i was too focused on
john cena's face wait
[Music]
wait listen listen to it i think that's
what they say
like their their kids are planning on
having
sex parties
maybe we just weren't invited
do i just totally expose myself as a
nerd
[Music]
well
if that's like american pie they all
plan to lose their virginity yeah at the
same time not the same place i think so
uh well that's the key yeah
i think our daughter's planning a sex
pack a sexy pack
different that's american pie for girls
yeah i guess so and then they try to the
dads try to yeah
but they're heading to one
party for you guys
hey guys i'm rachel and i'm allie and
welcome to our brand new podcast
bachelor happy hour that's right i hope
you have your wine rachel do you love
yours i stay with a glass of wine
because happy hour is the best hour and
that's what this hour is going to be all
right all right i like that and i feel
like the more wine that you get in us
the more bachelor secrets are going to
come out about our time on the show
right i mean i have a lot of them i know
you do ali i i think i'm already too
blunt and direct and i'm afraid of what
a couple of glasses of wine are going to
do i want to talk real quick about what
this podcast is going to be like i think
rachel that you and i have very very
unique perspective on what it's like to
be on the show so i feel like we are the
perfect people to host this podcast we
can also give you the behind the scenes
things too people always ask why is the
driveway so shiny that's because chris
harrison waters it so it looks nice and
shiny like why is it always wet was your
dress soaking wet on the first smoking
wet so heavy the worst thing trying to
go to the bathroom don't get me started
there's all weird behind the scenes
things like going to the bathroom
soaking wet gown well we'll get into
that i'm sure oh i'm excited allie i
think this is going to be so much fun so
you guys have to tune in it's going to
be amazing it's going to be so much fun
you gotta tune in as a bachelor super
fan because that is what i am you guys i
am so excited about the guests we are
going to have on the show i mean i'm not
just excited for you guys listening i'm
just excited for myself personally
because after the episodes i'm so like
oh my gosh i have to know what this
person was thinking and
on this podcast you are going to get to
hear from the guy or girl who was
eliminated on the last episode we're
gonna have the absolute latest breaking
news from them i mean they don't get
that rose they have a lot to say they're
gonna be right here on our podcast to
say it all right you guys so raise your
glass because bachelor happy hour is out
now you can find it on apple podcast
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts
you